y apenas empiece el curso escolar se
pondrá en marcha una campaña de refuerzo
de vacunas sin nombrarla directamente
emanuel macua y busca la famosa tercera
dosis y se destina por el momento a
aquellos que fueron los primeros en
vacunarse las personas mayores y la
población de riesgo todos aquellos que
en las próximas semanas y meses verán
bajar sus niveles de anticuerpos y
disminuir su inmunidad
las citas se podrán agendar a partir de
los primeros días de septiembre en un
momento en que la contagiosa variante
delta está provocando brotes en todo el
mundo surgen argumentos para una tercera
dosis con face by and tech liderando la
defensa de esta inyección según los
laboratorios debería administrarse seis
meses después de la segunda dosis
europa dice estar lista we are red y ya
estamos bien preparados posible
necesitamos eeuu es un poco más
reticente
nos estamos asegurando de tener tantas
opciones sobre la mesa como sea posible
para nosotros el pueblo
en israel ya se decidieron la inyección
de una tercera dosis comenzó para el
público llamado frágil pero el regulador
sanitario internacional ya advirtió que
una dosis adicional no está en la agenda
mundial while many countries
cuando muchos países ni siquiera han
empezado a vacunar y otros países se ha
vacunado a la mayoría de su población
con las dos dosis y ahora está pasando a
una tercera dosis que es el refuerzo es
seriamente decepcionante no tiene
sentido los wichis de booster según la o
ms los laboratorios deberían dirigir sus
dosis a los países subdesarrollados que
todavía tienen dificultades para
adquirir y administrar las primeras
dosis como áfrica
[Música]